[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
steve palazzolo pro football focus
senior analyst who joins us do you think
tony romo has any chance to get a hall
of fame induction
i think there's a chance i would
probably lean no though i think romo
probably lands in the uh proverbial hall
of the very good and i do think because
postseason moments do matter so much the
fact that eli is even being considered i
think that's going to end up working
against romo because he just doesn't
have it who do you think was a better
quarterback eli romo
i mean i think throw for throw roma was
a better quarterback i do think that the
postseason moments do matter and they
certainly will matter with the voters
but throw for throw you know if you're
just evaluating how well they played
yeah romo i think was better from from
start to finish more than eli eli had
some high peaks though that were really
really good including the super bowl
runs but do we over state overestimate
playoff success like that that seems to
be that that can decide whether you're
in or not
but
you know do we not give as much
importance to the regular season with
some of these quarterbacks
yeah i mean i think i think the
postseason stuff does matter though i
mean we're talking about the most
important position at sports and even
everything we do at pff is quantifying
and all that stuff and i even i'll
acknowledge there's something there's
something else when it comes to the post
there's something else that like
separates tom brady and separates guys
that do
uh execute the way they do in the
postseason so maybe we overrate it a
little bit but
um that's where philip rivers and tony
romo and those guys are going to end up
probably losing out a little bit oh so
you don't think philip rivers would go
into the hall of fame
the more i thought about it i was
thinking no i mean i i really think i've
got this like top five in my head right
top five of your era and if you're in
that you know top four or five it feels
like you should you should be in the
hall of fame rivers top eight type of
guy matt ryan top eight type of guy eli
honestly outside of the top eight or ten
even in his era romo is probably a top
eight guy in his era so to me they're
just on the outside looking in can you
get into the hall of fame now as a
quarterback without a super bowl
appearance
yeah i think you can uh appearance would
be tough without an appearance because
i'm thinking you know mourinho at least
made it to the super bowl but everybody
watched mourinho and said okay this is
the best quarterback in the league for a
big chunk of his career so i mean
technically you can but it's going to be
it's going to be really difficult
because the best quarterbacks usually at
least make it to a super bowl and
usually at least uh win at least one of
them uh we reached out to you with the
best and worst backup quarterback
situations here given the news with the
colts now it looks like carson wentz is
on course to start week one for the
colts against the uh seahawks so i don't
know if that changes your backup
quarterback situation or not there but
let's start with the good backup
quarterback situations right now
yeah so i look at teams that have guys
that i would consider you know low-end
starters that are sitting there as
backups so so the raiders have marcus
mariota you know if marcus mariota he's
not great he didn't become that
franchise quarterback that everybody
maybe was hoping but mariota is the best
backup in the nfl right now we might not
see a massive drop off if darren carr
got hurt
i think case keenum with the browns a
guy that could come in if baker bayfield
got hurt could come in run that offense
especially with the way kevin stefanski
calls plays and and you have to
highlight tamus down in new orleans
right whoever loses in the taysom hill
jameis winston battle there the other
guy becomes one of the better backups in
the entire league so i think the saints
might not know who their starter is but
they'll at least know that they've got
the best backups wait so they have two
high-end backups
but low-end starters that's right okay
the question was best backups right
so the saints win in that game how about
i also i have faith that jameis could be
a pretty good starter still if i give
you carson wentz or you can have tamus
together
who would you take
oh man
i would probably lean carson wentz and
that's because i do think he'll bounce
back from from last year's disaster but
uh but this is a you know it's
interesting yeah you could run you run
the ball with with taysom and i i have a
ton of faith in jamis but he needs
better playmakers than what they have
down in new orleans dolphins with jacoby
percent
yeah so i look at brisette again a guy
that
chris ballard was essentially in
indianapolis dealing with jacoby percent
he was kind of forced into the starting
lineup twice in his career i don't think
jacob besets a guy you want as a starter
but if you need to win four or five
games i think presets you know a good
solid option so miami you know could be
good there with briseta as their backup
all right the bad backup quarterback
situation
so i'm going to start with the teams
that have two of the elite quarterbacks
we've got patrick mahomes in kansas city
and russell wilson in seattle so if chad
henny had to take over in kansas city uh
he did that in the playoffs last year
had a couple good throws but some
disastrous ones almost threw the game
away i don't have a ton of faith in chad
henny take it over in kansas city and
then geno smith right now the top backup
in seattle i think that that offense
completely changes if it goes from russ
to geno smith i also think the ravens
have a massive question mark trace
mcsorley uh tyler huntley as the backups
they've both shown flashes but again i
think the drop-off from a lamar jackson
to whoever the ravens would trot out
there likely mcsorley i think would be
tough for the ravens what do you think
about the cowboys situation
so garrett gilbert right now the top
backup we just saw the hall of fame game
wasn't the wasn't the prettiest thing
the other night whether whether it was
garrett gilbert or ben dinucci
so uh gilbert again had some flashes
against the steelers a couple years ago
against their really good defense but
yeah the drop off uh it will be steeper
than what they had last year andy dalton
is one of the better backups in the
league if justin fields takes over but
yeah the cowboys having just garrett
gilbert right now would be a big
question mark i can't understand what
the jets are doing and i granted i've
said that quite a few times in my career
but you have james morgan and mike white
behind a rookie quarterback this is
crying out for
a nick foles or an andy dalton where you
have that experienced person a case
kingdom somebody who has experience
who's non-threatening to that
quarterback who can help them with you
know the nuance of of playing that
position
yeah i completely agree i think the jets
have made a lot of really smart moves
but the quarterback room is definitely a
questionable one maybe they just grabbed
josh mccown back from uh from television
right just bring him back as as the uh
as that guy that's in the qp room all
the time but i think it's a really good
point you know zach wilson needs to
learn
james morgan's never taken a snap mike
white hasn't played well in his
preseason action so um jets are making a
lot of smart moves but could definitely
use a veteran backup there i'm gonna
throw out some numbers here with uh romo
and eli
losing seasons as a
starter romo
zero eli five
seasons throwing more than fifteen
interceptions
romo two
eli eight
career completion
percentage romo 65 eli
60
yeah i mean romo was a better
quarterback you know um so
the the tricky part here and i think a
healthy internal debate if you were
running an nfl team would be would you
actually want the giants run would you
actually take that or would you want the
cowboys run would you want a quarterback
who is a volatile
and i use volatile in the terms of you
could be great or he could be terrible
that was eli right volatility but the
peaks are so good 2011 eli was so good
that they won a super bowl and he
carried them it wasn't like o7 he
carried them in 2011. do you want those
peaks do you want those two super bowls
but a bunch of years where you don't
make the playoffs or do you want to you
know get it on the green every single
year like the cowboys did with tony romo
and just kind of see what happens i
think it's an it's an honest question
that doesn't have a great answer and i
think depending on your perspective like
yeah give me the two championships like
eli brought us versus give me the
consistency that romo brought us but we
never got you know to the championship
games i think it's an honest and fair
question but yeah romo throw for throw
again was definitely a better
quarterback than eli manning good to
talk to you again steve thanks for
joining us as always
you got it thanks dan steve palazzolo
pro football focus senior analyst host
of uh pro football focus nfl podcast